[Musique]
maman
sur le plateau d' interdit d'interdire l
initiative de joe biden les ministres
des finances du g7 ont défini samedi
dernier à londres
un cadre pour l'imposition des
multinationales et un taux minimum
commun de 15% pour l'impôt sur les
sociétés un moyen de mettre fin au
dumping fiscal de ces dernières
décennies dont les modalités seront
discutées lors du g20 finances des 9 et
10 juillet à venise alors
s'achemine-t-on vers une régulation
fiscale mondiale pour en débattre nous
avons invité françois boulot vous êtes
avocat vous avez été le porte-parole des
gilet jaune de rouen est l'une des
principales figures du mouvement
depuis vous avez créé une chaîne youtube
que vous avez appelé praxis et vous avez
publié un livre intitulé reprendre le
pouvoir aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ces
mesures préconisées par le g7
oui je pense que sur le principe un
accord qui vient d'une coopération
internationale et qui a pour objectif de
réguler le marché et en particulier les
multinationales dont les gars fans
ça c'est une très bonne nouvelle
maintenant si on peut se réjouir sur le
principe de ski de l'annoncé qui vient
d'être faite
on en est qu'au stade de l'annonce est
d'ores et déjà je suis très réservé sur
le dispositif final qui sera qui sera
adoptée il ya beaucoup de choses dont on
peut déjà suspecté qu'elles sont
insuffisantes
à commencer par le taux de 15% qui en
réalité ne va pas radicalement changé la
donne du dumping fiscal auquel on
assiste depuis plusieurs années dans le
monde
michel où amy vous êtes économiste à la
banque de france et professeur à
sciences po et l escp europe
vous êtes un spécialiste du marché des
capitaux et de l'économie financière
alors est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à ces mesures
je veux qu'on fermerait ce que dit mon
collègue auparavant c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est on est d'accord sur le
principe la le dire en difficulté ça va
être la validation au niveau du g20
début juillet ce qui en tire est un peu
plus difficile et puis surtout sa mise
en oeuvre
parce qu'entre l'annoncé là hélas
résultat final on risque d'être un peu
plus on va dire avoir de grands écarts
donc bien sûr c'est une bonne voie
maintenant quid de dans la mise en
oeuvre et surtout je serai moins
favorable sur la taxation des gars
femmes où je pense les états unis
risquent de défendre leur entreprise
mais à qui vous vous êtes journaliste et
que demi que vous avez été rédactrice en
chef du magazine économique suisse bilan
de 2014 et 2019 d'être l'auteur du livre
le secret bancaire est mort vive
l'évasion fiscale c'était le secret
bancaire ensuite sains et de ubs les
dessous d'un scandale votre dernier
ouvrage c'est la finance de l'ombre a
pris le contrôle vous l'avez coécrit
avec dominique morisod c'est paru aux
éditions favre favorable ou pas
favorable à ces mesures annoncées
écoutez je pense que ces mesures ont été
souhaitées par les grands groupes
il faut pas oublier le rôle derrière les
états il faut pas voir que le g7 dans
cette décision
il ya beaucoup de failles dans ces 15%
de possibilités d'évitement on l'a déjà
vu pour amazon qui fait moins que la
marge bénéficiaire requises pour payer
les 15 % d'impôt donc à discuter mais à
priori défavorable c'est insatisfaisant
raphaël prado vous vous êtes porte
parole d'attac depuis 2010 cette attaque
c'est l'association pour la taxation des
transactions financières et pour
l'action citoyenne
nos organisations altermondialistes
créée en france en 1998 est présente
dans une quarantaine de pays
le dernier livre d'attac impôts idée
fausse et vraie injustice est sorti le
18 mai dernier aux liens qui libèrent
êtes également professeur agrégé de
sciences économiques et sociales
favorables ou pas favorable à ces à ce
taux à ces mesures annoncées bon on peut
que ce
li cité que la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale soit enfin en haut de l'agenda
politique et que le g7 finances est
consacré sa réunion à ça mais quand on
regarde dans le détail on aura
l'occasion de rediscuter jeune je pense
on peut douter de la sincérité des
déclarations qu'on trouve à part entre
le bruno le maire qui se félicite d'une
avancée historique de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale ou yann est celle qui
dit que ça va mettre fin à la
concurrence fiscale entre les états on
peut on peut être plus que sceptique
le taux annoncé est très faible c'est à
peine deux points et demi au dessus de
l'irlande
et puis surtout on peut craindre que ce
taux plancher puisse aussi devenir un
taux plafond c'est à dire puisse ensuite
incités à une pression pour faire
baisser les taux d'imposition sur les
sociétés dans les pays comme la france
où on a un taux supérieur
il ya d'autres limites qu'on pourra
développer j'imagine alors il ya deux
piliers 1 à 7
cette réforme si cette réforme a lieu le
premier c'est qu'on pourra taxer les
multinationales dans les pays où elles
ont leurs clients et leurs marchés alors
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont axés
uniquement là où elles sont implantées
ou là où se trouvent leurs sources leur
siège social c'est à dire généralement
en irlande à singapour ou luxembourg et
dans des pays comme ça qui sont plus ou
moins des des paradis fiscaux alors
est-ce que ce premier pays
ce premier pilier
vous semblent eux
convaincant et michel rémy c'est une
bonne approche puisque à supposer que
l'irlande ou les pays où se trouvent les
paradis fiscaux ne sut ne suivent pas
cette orientation et on va dire persiste
à conserver un taux plus bas
ça permet au pays on va dire dont les
qui ont 7 je dirais qu'ils enregistrent
ce chiffre d'affaires de pouvoir par
différentiel taxer ces pays donc en fait
première des choses c'est que ce taux de
15% à terme devrait faire disparaître
les paradis fiscaux
donc c'est une bonne chose maintenant
bien sûr comme a dit raphaël se pose la
question de savoir est ce que on va
abaisser le taux de fiscalité de l'impôt
sur les sociétés en général je ne le
pense pas je pense qu'on rentre dans un
autre système capitaliste que par
rapport au précédent dont bien sûr mais
il y a toujours des grandes manoeuvres
géopolitique derrière et je pense que il
y a aussi surtout les états unis qui
défendront aussi c'est leur entreprise
voilà notre acquis oui rappelons que joe
biden devait relever l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 21 à 28 % et qui finit cinq
mois plus tard par proposer un impôt
global de 15 % donc chercher l'erreur il
a fini par baisser les impôts chez lui
en tout cas pour ceux qui ne paient qui
ne paient rien et puis ceux qui vont
participer à cette fiscalisation c'est
finalement des multinationales qui ont
leur billet pour obtenir une certitude
pour tous les autres payer pour toutes
les autres juridictions qu'on est sur on
élimine la concurrence l'escale donc les
gars chats sont arrangées par ce système
parce que ce système va remplacer par
exemple les impôts qu'ils étaient
prélevées au royaume uni et dans lieu
sur les géants de la tech
ça va prendre la place et donc il se
garantissent à un plancher de 15 %
effectivement qui peut devenir la
nouvelle référence pour moi c'est une
baisse d'impôt globale par rapport aux
taux d'imposition même qui régnait aux
états unis aient compris sous tron on
est sur le taux d'imposition le plus bas
de l'histoire depuis les années 40 sous
margaret thatcher on était on était allé
2 52% à 3
quatre sont tout à la fin de son mandat
et sous régal qu'on était passé de 45 %
à 35 % et maintenant on n'arrive même
pas à avoir des impôts de 25 %
donc il faut clairement se poser la
question de ce niveau de 15% qui est
souhaitée en fait par les
multinationales
il faut c'est que facebook et les gars
femmes en général google microsoft
amazon sont devenus le plus gros lot dit
maintenant à bruxelles ça a été très
documentée par une ong un corps
torreilles europe basauri et aux etats
unis ils ont massivement massivement
augmenté leur lobbying aussi donc dès
qu'ils ont su que byden proposerait une
hausse de 28% sur les corporations
ils ont commencé déjà à trouver cet
arrangement qui assure finalement aux
états unis que tous les autres pays vont
pas être plus compétitif que donc il
faut voir qui c'est qui gagnent là dans
les petits pays perde la fin de la
concurrence fiscale c'est pas forcément
une chose souhaitable
l'autoritarisme et le cartel fiscale
imposée par un groupe de puissance avec
des grandes multinationales qui ont été
consultés évidemment ce n'est pas
forcément ce qu'on recherche vraiment
pour fiscaliser de manière territoriale
et souveraine ces grands bouts mirettes
vous pensez que la france devra retirer
sa taxe sur les entreprises numériques
par exemple
absolument ça c'est certain que 7 15%
pas la remplacer
d'accord prochain boulot sur le premier
pilier
oui mais oui je crois que la bombe sur
l'aspect technique et iphone
il faut articuler les deux en fait si je
répondais aux observations qui viennent
d'être faites parce que effectivement
c'est 15 % minimum et puis d'un autre
côté il va falloir articuler la question
de la transparence fiscale des
multinationales
plus précisément savoir où elles ont
fait leur chiffre d'affaires dans quel
pays pour que à chaque fois les recettes
fiscales de chaque pays reviennent bien
au pays dans lequel l'activité et j' ai
fait des pratiques et par l'entreprise
considérée mais avant d'aller plus loin
je dirais sur les quais sur ces
questions techniques choisies il faut
quand même se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
alors que ça fait des années que ce
problème là se pose pourquoi enfin on a
une annonce en tout cas un début de
commencement de
volonté de taxer à l'échelle mondiale
les multinationales choix qu'il faut
bien comprendre ce qui est en train de
se jouer dans le monde depuis des années
on a une compétition qui s'est faite
entre le marché les états-nations que
pendant des années depuis les années
1980 seul marché qui n'a eu de cesse que
de gagner en pouvoir et de d'augmenter
son emprise sur les sur les états
nations et puis il ya eu à la faveur des
révoltes populaires qui se sont déroulés
à la fois aux états unis en france
les gilets jaunes en amérique du sud
bref on a vu sur les derniers mois les
dernières années un mécontentement de
des classes moyennes des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes
aux états unis ça s'est traduit par
l'arrivée de trump au pouvoir et qui
s'est achevée par les événements du
capitole et je crois que aux états unis
les classes dominantes
parce que je crois je parle classes
dominantes parce que je crois que la
lutte des classes au sens des rapports
de force qui s'exprime au sein de la
société ou des sociétés humaines est
fondamentale pour comprendre ce qui se
joue les classes dominantes ont compris
aux états unis qu'il faut changer de
braquet
on peut plus se permettre de laisser le
marché à avoir les pleins pouvoirs parce
que ça conduit à des inégalités qui sont
beaucoup trop forte
un chômage de masse dans les pays
développés et a effectivement une
paupérisation de la classe moyenne et on
a eu d'ailleurs une baisse du niveau de
vie aux etats unis
si bien que désormais les états unis
sont à la manoeuvre pour essayer d'enfin
réguler le marché et moi ce que je
relève c'est que les européens encore
une fois son talent hamas encore une
fois n'ont rien compris parce que si on
est à 15 % aujourd'hui minimum il faut
bien expliquer que byden lui souhaite un
taux à 21 % minimum et c'est les
européens et en particulier ma la france
et l'allemagne qui veulent en réalité un
taux à 12 5% c'est-à-dire l'auto qui est
pratiqué par l'irlande
donc c'est l'union européenne
aujourd'hui qui parle gangréné par ces
lobbys effectivement est en train
d'essayer de savonner cet accord est ce
ce dispositif qui pourrait véritablement
être historique et je crois
véritablement clos en europe on ne
comprend pas aujourd'hui ce qu'est le
sens de l'histoire et ça je peut que le
déplorer en définitive on à baden qui
est en train en six mois de données
quand même des leçons de politique
alors certes on verra si si
mots sont suivies d'effet mais en tout
cas il met sur la table des propositions
concrètes avec des taux de fiscalité et
on a nous en europe et je pense
évidemment en particulier emmanuel
macron des gens qui ne font que du verbe
qui ne font que parler qui nous promet
de croissance et prospérité
mais qui ne savent plus faire de la
politique par les actes et je crois que
là le c'est une cinglante leçon que les
états unis sont en train de donner à
l'europe et en particulier à l'union
européenne et à la france
mais pardon mais pourquoi pensez-vous
que la france a intérêt à ce que la peau
sur les sociétés soit au niveau de celui
de l'irlande alors que nous mêmes le
nôtre est bien plus gros
on a tout à perdre dans cette histoire
qu'est ce que pourquoi la france elle
serait match de schiste eh bien écoutez
moi je cherche l'intérêt jeu qu'on
m'explique pourquoi l'union européenne
qui existe depuis un petit moment en
principe aller on va prendre depuis
maastricht depuis maastricht où on a
fait de marché unique et on a fait
l'euro donc l'union européenne qui est
censé créer la coopération entre les
états membres de l'union européenne n'a
pas eu l'idée de mettre en place ce que
joe biden les états unis sont en train
de proposer pourquoi ils ne le font pas
en réalité vous avez une union
européenne qui est basée sur la règle de
la concurrence qui a organisé le dumping
social et fiscal et qui je crois de
manière complètement absurde croit
peut-être trouver intérêt à ce que
l'irlande attire des sièges sociaux de
grandes firmes notamment américaines
pour essayer de les imposer
je crois que ce calcul il est
complètement perdant il est complètement
stupide
en tout cas pour la france c'est on le
voit bien que l'union européenne a été
qu un carcan et donc effectivement je
crois qu'on joue contre nos intérêts
mais c'est si les dirigeants politiques
français servait les intérêts de la
france et quand je dis la france parle
des français du peuple français plutôt
que les intérêts du lobby bancaire
deux des grandes entreprises françaises
du cac 40 etc
je crois que ça se saurait je pense que
on a une union européenne et la france
qui est gangréné effectivement par les
allégeances la corruption les influences
diverses et variées et effectivement
tout ça ne sert pas du tout les intérêts
du pays
sinon on aura une croissance qui
marcherait on se serait pas d un triste
réalisé comme comme on l'est aujourd'hui
et on n'aimerait pas une fraude fiscale
est évalué à 100 milliards par an et
dont je sais mon mot pour conclure mon
intervention
on n'a même pas de méthode aujourd'hui
d'évaluation de la fraude fiscale loge
dans le pays
les états ils ont depuis les années 80
le un certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne notamment le royaume-uni
depuis le début des années 2000 ont pris
le problème à bras le corps nous en 2021
en france bercy n'a toujours pas de
méthode d'évaluation de la fraude
fiscale voilà où on en est donc a pas de
volonté de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale
mais la dja qui n'avait pas l'air
d'accord oui oui parce que j'aimerais un
bond à matthieu boulo que vous idéalisez
beaucoup trop les états unis et tout ce
que vous dites sur la france et l'europe
est encore plus vrai mais multiplié par
10 pour les etats unis c'est à dire que
byden il a fait campagne
souvenez-vous sur une hausse de 21% à
28% et il lui arrivait un scénario
exactement comme françois hollande quand
en 2012 il a proposé de mettre 75 % sur
les plus hauts revenus
eq après c'est parti en sucette
souvenez-vous il lui arrive est
exactement la même chose
à partir du moment où il a été élu le
lobbying a démarré on lui a dit écoutez
votre projet avec 28 % c'est pas
possible
en mai dernier ils nous ont dit
finalement il va relever de battes et à
1 25% et voulait pas dire 28 voulait
dire 25 est maintenant dans son projet
d'infrastructure il a divisé par 2 2 2
trilliard un trial ce qui va lever et
les mêmes plus question de hausses
d'impôts donc il s'est complètement
reporter sur ce projet de l'oscd que
madame jelen le trésor américain l'osce
et de le ramener vraiment sur un plateau
d'argent pour le sauver pour le tirer
d'affaires parce que les américains
l'ont élu pour qu'il hausse les impôts
américains sur les entreprises à 28%
ce que je répète est beaucoup plus bas
que le taux le plus bas que regan avait
mis et donc il n'a pas pu parce que les
républicains l'ont bloquée exactement
comme ce que vous dites sur ce qui se
passe en france ou dans l'union
européenne
il a été bloqué mais vraiment comme un
débutant face aux républicains et
maintenant ils se reportent sur 1 15%
qui est beaucoup plus bas que ses
propres impôts et que toute l'histoire
des impôts sur les entreprises aux états
unis depuis les années 40
parce qu'il n'a pas le choix parce qu'il
a essuyé un échec cuisant que né le
washington post et le new york times noz
reconnaître en septembre mais qu'il
existe quand même tous les jours ils
nous le raconte
entre les lignes cet échec donc non les
états unis sont pas du tout un modèle de
gouvernance au maintien ils veulent
juste que tous les pays
si eux sont obligés parce qu'ils sont
ruinés d'avoir des impôts sur les
entreprises
ils veulent juste que tous les autres
pays soient aussi peu compétitif que en
tout cas pas plus compétitifs parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont coincés ils
doivent lever des impôts parce qu'il
doit s'occuper de leurs achats structure
le royaume uni c'est la même chose avec
15% d'ailleurs ils n'y arriveront pas
nous n'arrivons pas à faire des ponts
des routes des choses c est tout ce qui
peut le faire ça ne suffira pas parce
qu'ils vont lever finalement les
républicains manon des 500 milliards ça
suffira alors que le projet initial de
joe baïda sur laquelle les américains
l'ont élu c'était 2-2 triglia de 2000
milliards donc de douala pad oh oui joue
sur le sur le ventre sur le premier
pilier et les modalités
parce que évidemment ça devrait toucher
les multinationales qui font plus de 20
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
+ 10 % de bénéfices ce qui fait que
amazon n'est pas dedans par exemple ça
montre ce que ce que je disais en
introduction c'est que en soit m un taux
d'impôt minimum sur les sociétés ça peut
être une bonne idée nous c'est pas
l'idée qu'on défend un texte pour
expliquer tout à l'heure pourquoi on
préfère le principe de taxation unitaire
mais ça peut être une bonne idée si on
arrive à un taux qui est élevé par
exemple le taux de 25% qui est
préconisée par les économistes de
licques riscle avec duc manh notamment
dedans là on peut être frappé quand même
par le faible montant des recettes qui
sont annoncés gabriel zucman notamment a
calculé qu'avec un taux à 15 % on a
honoré 4 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires en france par an alors
qu'avec un taux à 21%
ça ferait 16 milliards et un taux à 25 %
dont tel qu'il préconise ça ferait 26
milliards donc c'est vrai que là ce 4
milliards c'est déjà des ailes faible et
quand on écoute maintenant bruno le
ou le reste du gouvenement expliqué dans
les médias on se rend compte qu'en fait
c'est on n'arrive même pas à ces quatre
milliards d'euros
parce qu'en fait il va y avoir des trous
dans la raquette parce que c'est
toujours intéressant de regarder le taux
mais parlant si on regarde en france le
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés il al'air
élevé mais il ya tellement de trous dans
la raquette ses talents de l'assiette
fiscale est tellement faible qu'en
réalité la part de l'impôt sur les
sociétés dans dans le pib et les pays
les plus faibles que dans d'autres pays
quoi donc là on a on a effectivement
cette idée que ça va être un montant
très faible et d'ailleurs ils commencent
à nous dire ah ça va être supérieur à la
taxe gaffard donc on va supprimer la
taxe bien fait on s'est engagé à
supprimer la taxe gaza alors je voudrais
rappeler là dessus qu'ils attaquent on
avait sorti menottes pour décrypter
attacks gaza et on avait un plan d
absolument pas ce qu'elle prétendait
combattre et que ce soit la taxe pierre
fayet roues avec aujourd'hui ce qui nous
est proposé
on ne va absolument pas régler la
difficulté qui est que les
multinationales celles qui font le plus
gros chiffre d'affaires mais aussi les
plus importants profits
celle qui devrait le plus contribué à
l'impôt sur celle finalement qui
échappent le plus et on va on en train
d'analyser un taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés qui est beaucoup plus faible
pour les multinationales que pour les
tpe et les pme qui n'ont pas de filiale
au luxembourg ou à jersey pour
délocaliser artificiellement leurs
profits alors je voudrais revenir aussi
sur ce qu'a dit françois belot qui sont
très important c'est que si les
gouvernements aujourd'hui se sentent
obligés d'agir
et même si on peut considérer qu'ils
font semblant de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale il lutte il le met en tout cas à
l'ordre du jour je pense que c'est
important de rappeler que aux etats-unis
comme en france on a un sentiment
d'injustice fiscale qui est très fort on
l'a vu aux états unis avec la campagne
des démocrates notamment la primaire où
c'étaient des question centrale comment
est ce possible que amazon impôts et que
enfin j'ai entendu plusieurs fois cette
phrase date avec différentes
multinationales qui payent moins
d'impôts que que que vous et moi mais on
l'a vu aussi en france évidemment avec
le mouvement des gilet jaune et on
continue à le voir aujourd'hui avec un
prix
dis donc il ya une politique car a dit
coco aux plus grandes entreprises
et là je voudrais finir en répondant à
la question vous avez posé tout à
l'heure sur pourquoi la france ne lutte
pas contre l'évasion fiscale alors
qu'elle y aurait intérêt
on est bien obligé de constater que
l'état mène une politique favorable aux
entreprises du cac 40
et là quand on regarde effectivement par
exemple comment se comportent les
entreprises dans l'état dans lesquelles
l'état est encore actionnaire par
rapport aux entreprises du cac 40 qui
sont totalement privés on voit bien que
ces entreprises ne sont pas du tout
vertueuse que cela et angie ou ou au
noël sont pas du tout vertueuse elles
ont elles aussi leur siège dans les
paradis fiscaux elle se débrouille elle
aussi pour ne pas payer d'impôts pour
échapper à l'impôt nos compet on est un
état qui est totalement schizophrène qui
d'un côté a besoin de recettes pour
financer
je vais pas développer ici mais tout ce
qui a besoin
l'association écologique les
investissements dans les services
publics et qui en même temps se prive de
recettes et c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
une crainte par rapport à tout ce qu'on
a ce qu'on est en train de discuter
c'est que on est en train d'analyser le
fait que les grandes entreprises vont
payer moins d'impôts que les autres et
on est en train de d'avaliser cette
course vers le bas des taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés il faut admettre que les
téléspecteurs les spectateurs et les
téléspectatrices comprennent que si ce
ne sont pas les entreprises
multinationales qui paient les impôts
s'ils ne sont pas non plus les plus
riches parce que le taux d'impôt sur les
plus riches
on n'a fait que diminuer et bien alors
ça va être vous qui allez payer
notamment sous forme de tva des taxes à
la consommation où on l'a vu par exemple
avec le mouvement des gilets jaunes sur
des taxes qui sont qui peuvent paraître
écologique soit principe mais qui en
réalité sont injustes parce qu'elles
sont supportés bien plus lourdement par
les plus pauvres que par les plus riches
donc là on en est là aujourd'hui où on a
réussi nous on peut s'en féliciter a
attaqué puis bien sûr toutes les
autorisations qui minutes timides pour
la justice fiscale on a réussi à faire
monter ce sentiment d'injustice fiscale
et que nos gouvernements scandale après
scandale et notamment après les
paradoxes peppers commencé à dire il va
falloir faire de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale une priorité
malheureusement les sommes qu'ils sont a
indiqué sont très très faible à talca
fall a rapporté 400 millions l'an
dernier
et apparemment le pilier 1 va pas
rapporter beaucoup plus donc
ça reste absolument dérisoires à la fois
par rapport à ce que devrait payer les
multinationales si elles payer leur
juste part d'impôts mais aussi par
rapport aux besoins immenses qu'on a
pour financer nos services publics et la
transition écologique clan c'est a
priori c'est que ça devrait toucher une
centaine de multinationales une fois les
critères établis et pas seulement les
entreprises du numérique comme on
pouvait l'imaginer on l'a dit amazon va
y échapper puisque amazon fait des
bénéfices en dessous d'eux en dessous du
seuil minimum nécessaire pour être
imposée mais je crois que gilbert
ne sera pas dedans non plus ni airbnb en
revanche à des multinationales
françaises comme air liquide ou l'oréal
ou ou lvmh qui vont tomber sous tout à
coup qui seront soumises à ce à cette
nouvelle réglementation oui à dernier
mot myret zaki la juste frédéric leleu
amazon face aux critiques et ceux qui
proposent cette règle de 15 pour cent
ont dit non ce sera possible de prendre
la division d'amazon qui fait plus que
10% de marge bénéficiaire est là on va
pouvoir l'a taxé à 15%
donc ça veut dire qu'en fait on va
pouvoir taxer les divisions des
multinationales qui font 15% il essaye
de sauver leur la proposition de cette
manière bon en réalité le même
raisonnement peut être appliquée pour
dire ok mais on peut saucissonner les
divisions d'une multinationale
lvmh par exemple pour faire en sorte
qu'aucune des divisions n'y ait plus de
10% de marge bénéficiaire donc ça se
sait c'est tout à fait possible de
trouver des échappatoires par rapport à
cette histoire de 10% de marge qui
n'aurait pas dû figurer dans le front
dans cette proposition parce que si on
arrive avec directement d échappatoire
possible on mime finalement la
crédibilité de cette loi effectivement
on part d'une situation où la plupart de
ces multinationales par exemple 55% de
parts dont 55 entreprises de fortune
five hundred ont payé zéro impôt fédéral
sur le revenu en 2020 aux états unis à
force de crédit d'impôt pour la
recherche et le développement et de
taxes brakes et autres cadeaux fiscaux
qui ont été données par exemple par le
gouvernement américain c'est pareil
aussi en france en europe ou uk ou les
cadeaux fiscaux aux multinationales
c'est quelque chose de très courant ce
qui fait qu'ils ne payent jamais même le
taux effectif et donc il était tellement
bas que comparé au fait qu'ils échappent
et tellement à des impôts il 15% sa part
est déjà beaucoup
mais soyons clairs moi j'aimerais dire
quelque chose de très très très clairs
là
c'est important d'éliminer les refuges
fiscaux dans des juridictions offshore d
pour les multinationales la démarche en
elle même elle ne peut pas être contesté
qu'elle a à un moment donné pour qu'on
arrive à ce qu'il n'y ait plus aucun
aucune juridictions opaques ou ses
sièges peuvent être déplacées ou des
profits peuvent être déplacées donc sur
le principe on est d'accord mais sur les
modalités c'est vraiment pas crédible et
ça va pas pouvoir être efficace
bon ben on fait une pause et puis je
devrais la parole à michel où amy parce
qu'on a très peu entendu jusqu'à présent
vous
[Musique]
bitcoin dodge kahina cardinaux tous des
crypto actifs mais ces dernières
semaines pour 2 4 le cours du bitcoin
s'effondre elle perd 30% de sa valeur en
quelques jours on peut difficilement
pour l'instant parler de trash vous avez
quelque chose est monté jusqu'à 60 mille
euros et qui est redescendu à 30 mais ça
vaut encore trente mille euros plus un
marché est petit plus évidemment il est
sujet à de la volatilité
c'est la vie d'un actif comme comme
bitcoin que de subir ce genre de crash
on essaie de vendre ça comme quelque
chose de tout à fait tranquille et qui
ne peut que monter non ça à 200 bourses
hommes mais comme tout je rappelle que
dans le monde il ya presque un milliard
de personnes qui ont vu en 2020 leurs
monnaies nationales se dépréciait de
plus de 20%
effectivement c'est une ça peut être une
monnaie d'échangé pour ces gens là donc
la monnaie est ce qu'elle fait en
l'occurrence si les gens s'en servent
comme d'une monnaie il faudra l'accepter
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans les
relations entre la russie aujourd'hui
venir travailler en russie
nouer des partenariats pose des
problèmes dans la mesure où vous pouvez
être confronté à un partenaire qui est
sous sanction notamment américaines le
commerce ne se développe pas ah non ils
ont fait entre la france je pensais la
russie maintenant elle joue très frustré
dire que la russie produits russes mais
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il pourrait
s'affranchir de la surpuissance des gaza
par exemple s'affranchisse de la
technologie européenne pour pour tous se
développer des entreprises françaises
qui ont un futur en russie ce sont
celles qui peuvent leur apporter à
savoir faire après la question et ça va
parce qu'elles resteront
ep
[Musique]
repro ce débat avec françois boulot avec
michel remy myret zaki et raphaël prado
michel rémy j'ai besoin de vos lumières
pour que l'on comprenne bien de quoi il
s'agit techniquement on l'a dit les les
bénéfices mondiaux vont être répartis
des multinationales vont être répartis
entre les pays où elle opère c'est comme
ça que ça c'est le premier pilier le 2e
pilier
c'est que il y aura un niveau
d'imposition minimum de 15% et que la
différence devra être payée par les
multinationales qui serait par exemple
toujours en irlande imposé à 12 5%
elles devront payer la différence mais à
qui a priori c'est à leur pays d'origine
donc en fait cet argent il va revenir
aux états unis comme si elles veulent
match il va revenir en france pour finir
à pas dans les autres pays
en effet alors que je voulais revenir
sur la première partie c'est que on est
en train de discuter du taux de 15%
c'est suffisant pas suffisant sur les
modalités de fuites etc etc
je pense que ce qu'il convient de voir
c'est que une première victoire sera que
l'acceptation par l'ensemble des pays de
cette taxe
or pour l'instant elle n'est pas acté il
faut attendre le g20 de de début juillet
pour que ça va avec soit actée et je
pense qu'il ya des réticences au niveau
des pays émergents je pense aussi qu'ils
rendraient tire sa ans au pays dont on
va dire des pays des paradis fiscaux
donc là aussi il n'est pas certain que
cela soit on va dire actes et bien sûr
il ya des états unis bien sûr que
l'union européenne mais ce qui va ce qui
vaut bien se rendre compte c'est que
cette instauration risque de cet axe
crise de prendre en considération
d'autres considérations d'autres pays et
non pas uniquement les considérations
américaines et européennes alors pour
revenir à cette question de savoir quel
est le différentiel à supposer que
une entreprise si l'irlande continuent à
taxer à nous et demi pour cent et que
cette taxe existe à 15% et bien le pays
d'origine récupérera ses deux ennemis
mais en fait quelle est l'idée là dessus
c'est que quel serait l'intérêt
admettons si je prends facebook qui ont
va dire de optimiser fiscalement ses
bénéfices en soumettant en irlande alors
que de toute façon elle irait il
conviendrait d'aller vers les états unis
où dans d'autres pays
mais l'idée est que il ya une
récupération du pays d'origine on va
dire de on va dire de nature de
l'origine du p de la société ou de la
firme taxer et donc bien sûr on y
retrouve
mais au-delà de ces différentiels c'est
qu'on veut gommer l'ensemble des paradis
fiscaux comme on le voit officiellement
comme l'irlande mais également on peut
voir l'irlande on peut voir singapour
vers d'autres choses et là aussi c'est
ça qu'il faut venir voir c'est qu'à
terme on risque d'avoir une amortie
nations unes pendant un amortissement de
tout cesser ces paradis fiscaux il
reviendrait à la discussion de deux
mirettes en disant oui bien finalement
l'ensemble des paradis fiscaux on aura
un traitement égalitaire et les paradis
fiscaux nombreux mais plus aucun intérêt
pour ces firmes et et deuxièmement alors
la façon dont on va répartir entre les
pays où opèrent les multinationales on
l'a dit ça c'est le premier pilier que
les multinationales ne cesse de payer
des impôts que dans les pays où ils sont
implantés où ils ont leur siège
généralement des paradis fiscaux et que
cet argent qui payent des impôts six
corps du mois que cet argent soit
réparti également on a parlé de 20% du
chiffre d'affaires va répartis dans les
pays où il opère vraiment ça c'est
possible ça techniquement
techniquement ça sera sur une base
d'estimations en fait l'impôt sur les
sociétés est basé sur la territorialité
c'est-à-dire leur ont offert chiffre
d'affaires je paye l'impôt
or aujourd'hui vous voyez bien qu'avec
les activités dématérialisé donc je
trouve appelez l'internet
je peux très bien acheter sur amazon ou
un produit et le bénéfice va aller sur
amazon qui va qui a son siège peu
ailleurs donc on voit bien que d'une
certaine manière au luxembourg donc
l'idée est que ça
la taxation ra à luxembourg donc là
qu'est ce qu'on fait on dit non on va
estimer le chiffre d'affaires on va dire
nationale et en conséquence la firme
multinationale père à une quote-part
deux sets de 7 ce chiffre d'affaires au
pays où est réalisé le chiffre
d'affaires estimé
enfin le prado et un bug j'ai
l'impression chez elle ce qui en limite
de ce qui nous est proposé c'est que
quand on voit il ya un article du monde
hier soir là où il y avait une affection
sûrement pour estimer qu'elle monte ans
à l'ehess allait rapporter tout ça et
effectivement apparemment allée des
gaffes à vont être taxés aux états unis
les multinationales françaises moins
taxés vont apporter un peu plus de
recettes en france en soi c'est très
bien qu'elle paye un peu plus d'impôts
quelle qu elle pratique un peu moins
d'évasion fiscale mais peut quand même
se poser la question le g7 c'est le club
des pays riches c'est le club des pays
industrialisés du deuxième moitié du 20e
siècle
est-ce que ce g7 il est vraiment
légitime pour définir les grandes
orientations de ce que doit être la
fiscalité mondiale alors je sais bien
qu'après ça mais discutée dans le cadre
du g20 ou de l'ocb ray mais ça reste des
clubs de pays riches et de grandes
puissances et on apporte à craindre ici
que les pays les plus pauvres et les
pays du sud qui sont les principales
victimes de l'évasion fiscale en
pourcentage de leur pib ça a été montré
ma bonne foi et bien sûr les grandes
perdantes de cet accord et récupère
seulement quelques miettes
donc là j'aimerais quand même attiré
l'attention sur le fait qu' on débat
d'un accord en se demandant si c'est
bien ou pas bien mais on n'a pas posé la
question de est-ce que c'est légitime
que ce soit les pays du g7 qui annoncent
cet accord qui les a mandatés pour faire
cette cette discussion est est-ce que
c'est légitime que ce soit des pays qui
dont les multinationales sont celles qui
sont les principales en veine il a faim
bénéficiaires de l'évasion fiscale et en
mots qu'on sait que les gouvernements ne
sont pas leurs sont principalement au
style est-ce que c'est légitime que ça
soit veut mener la danse dans les
discussions et ça que quand on voit les
raies
actions les différents gaza est cet
accord on peut se dire qu'a priori ils y
trouvent leur compte aussi et donc ça
quand même ça ça ça pose la question est
alors pour répondre à une question vous
est posée c'est pour ça que nous on
préfère largement le principe de la
taxation unitaire à ce taux minimum la
taxation unitaire alors ça suppose la
transparence fiscale à laquelle la
france s'était opposée par ailleurs en
recopiant les desiderata du medef mais
si on a la transparence fiscale si on
sait exactement quelles sont les
activités de chaque multinationales dans
chaque pays combien de salariés qu'ils
ont
combien de chiffre d'affaires quand même
des bénéfices combien d'impôts elle paye
alors on pourrait instaurer cette
taxation unitaire c'est à dire
considérer les multinationales comme un
tout une seule entreprise plutôt que de
faire semblant que ce sont des filiales
et que par exemple amazon réaliste
d'activité au luxembourg ce qui a
évidemment invraisemblable eh bien on
considère comme un tour on estime
qu'elle est leur activité réelle dans
chaque pays et au prorata de ceux ci on
va appliquer le taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés dans chaque pays et ça
permettrait selon comment le calcul
d'être juste y compris avec les pays du
sud puisque on sait qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple beaucoup de beaucoup de produits
sont fabriqués dans les pays du sud est
consommée dans les pays du nord et du
coup quand on regarde uniquement le
chiffre d'affaires non seulement ce
chiffre d'affaires il a en grande partie
évadé mais en plus ce chiffre d'affaires
il représente pas là où la régie ils
répondent pas forcément très bien là où
la richesse a été créé et donc il
faudrait qu'on réfléchisse à une manière
de faire et ecep taxation et r ça
permettrait qu'effectivement les
multinationales père réellement leurs
impôts là où elles réalisent leurs
activités et si on veut que ce soit le
lait la méthode on va dire du g7 ou
celle que préconise attaque
si on veut re parvenir à une régulation
fiscale mondiale est ce que ce que vous
avez l'air de souhaiter françois boulot
vous l'avez dit
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut il n'y a
qu'un gouverneur une gouvernance
mondiale qui petit parvenir
si on veut que les forces du marché
cesse de progresser sans arrêt et au
détriment particulier des états le seul
moyen c'est une gouvernance mondiale
sinon on n'y arrivera jamais
qu'en pensez vous je pense que notre
question elle est très bonne alors juste
avant d'y répondre je voudrais répondre
à raphaël prado juste pour dire que
j'étais d'accord je souscris à tout ce
qu'il a dit sauf à l'argument qui
consiste à d a contesté la méthode et le
fait que le g7 soit à l'initiative soit
un problème
bon je pense qu'il faut bien commencer
par quelque part il n'ya pas d'instances
internationales justement il n'y a pas
de gouvernance mondiale supranationale
qui existe aujourd'hui
oui évidemment c'est les pays les plus
riches qui abrite les multinationales
qui ne peuvent qu il n'y a qu'elle qui
peuvent être enfin ces pays-là qui
peuvent être à l'initiative après en
revanche il a raison de dire qu' il
faudra se montrer critique s'il le faut
et à mon avis il y aura des raisons de
l'être sur le fait que cet accord soit
inéquitable pour les pays du sud ensuite
je vais répondre à venir et zaki qui me
reprocher d'idéaliser joe biden et sa
politique et peut-être même l'accord en
réalité je suis dupe de rien l'accord il
est très insuffisant par son taux je les
dis aussi parce qu'on ne sait pas très
clairement encore les règles de
transparence fiscale qui on est exigée
auprès des multinationales
on ne sait pas non plus quels seront les
sanctions en cas de non respect soit par
une multinationale soit par un état des
dispositifs de l'accord peut-il y avoir
une instance pour réguler pour
sanctionner les états et les
multinationales qui qui ne respectera
pas les termes de cet accord bon donc je
suis pas dupe déjà des effets je le
dédie cet accord à mon avis en l'état ne
produira pas beaucoup d'effets concrets
pour améliorer les recettes fiscales des
états et la justice fiscale
on va dire au sein des pays en revanche
le joe biden apporte quelque chose de
nouveau et je me lit d alice pas je sais
d'où il vient je sais qu'il fait partie
des établissements américains etc
mais quand même ils changent de discours
ça fait quand même 40 ans qu'on nous a
expliqué que c'était zéro is no
alternative et qu'on pouvait pas faire
autrement et entre eux un nicolas
sarkozy qui post crise de milieu 800
pride nous explique qui va moraliser le
capitalisme et notamment le capitalisme
financier c'est-à-dire une formule
incantatoire et un job hayden qui certes
peut-être ne fait pas ce qu'il a dit
qu'il ferait notamment parce qu'il est
bloqué par les républicains pour
augmenter de l'impôt sur les sociétés
certes il peut pas le faire mais
n'empêche que son discours ces mots
s'accompagne de propositions concrètes
de propositions d'actes politiques et
qui seraient posés ça veut dire qu'à
nous tous qui
je crois militons pour une meilleure
justice fiscale on a des arguments
solides la faire valoir ça nous donne un
levier très puissant notamment en france
où on a des dirigeants politiques qui
nous explique encore aujourd'hui que
c'est la théorie du ruissellement à
réflexion alors ma chronique du dit non
c'est pas la théorie du ruissellement cd
premier de cordée mais enfin ça ça veut
dire eux mêmes et c'est d'ailleurs parce
que ces gens-là pense qu'il faut
maximiser les profits des plus riches
parce que c'est le petit frère de la
santé des économies et la croissance que
ils ont aucune heure aucun intérêt à
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale puisque
le riche va s'enrichir beaucoup plus
encore avec les réseaux fiscal dont 10
il va investir encore plus dans leur
logique voilà pourquoi ils luttent pas
contre l'évasion fiscale
donc je suis dupe de rien mais
simplement je veux quand même souligner
cette différence entre baden et macro
pour résumer choses simplement et
ensuite j'en arrive à votre question on
fabrique taddei parce que je signalais
aussi la rupture qu'il ya entre la
politique américaine qui est en train là
de faire une proposition de coopération
internationale d'un accord international
qui s'y sentent une coopération entre
les états qui ne peut qu ils ne portent
pas donc atteinte à la souveraineté des
états qui ne consiste pas en des
délégations de souveraineté et en cela
je l'oppose à l'union européenne qui
fonctionne sur une des délits est sous
de souveraineté notamment en matière
économique j'ai déjà beaucoup expliqué
faye la france n'est plus maître de sa
politique économique
elle n'a pas la maîtrise de son budget
ni ça venait ni de sa politique
commerciale
donc on est face à ceux à ce choix
après il mais il faut l'assumer c'est à
dire soit on veut une instance
supranationale à laquelle on
consentirait des déviations de
souveraineté et donc les états ne serait
plus maître de leurs politiques
économiques
en tout cas on va dire que de leurs
politiques fiscales et on peut faire ça
mais alors on assume on sort de la
démocratie parce que la démocratie ça ne
se fait qu'à l'échelle de la nation à
l'échelle d'un peuple qui est cimentée
par une condition de solidarité un
sentiment de solidarité un esprit commun
qui se fonde sur une histoire une
culture une langue commune et la
démocratie suppose une condition
nécessaire la possibilité de dit libéré
de tout tout le temps partout en toutes
circonstances et donc de changer
d'orientation
si le peuple ne décide donc dès
l'instant françois boulay ob dans ce que
vous voulez dire à ce moment là il
landes est parfaitement dans son droit
est parfaitement justifiée à faire un
taux d'imposition à 12 5% et pourquoi
pas demain à 8%
elle pourrait dire écoutez moi je suis
désolé j'ai pas des grandes entreprises
comme vous donc le seul moyen d'attirer
les capitaux
c'est de leur vendre un ou deux hommes
ping fiscale et c'est ce que je fais et
je vois pas au nom de quoi
je m'opposerai ou jeu je renoncerai à ce
privilège démocratique pour vous faire
plaisir à vous les nations qui est déjà
extrêmement puissante est extrêmement
riche et qui voulait en plus avoir des
taux d'imposition élevé et que je me
malines dessus mais exactement alors
c'est là où entre on entre dans la
logique claire mandat géopolitiques et
des rapports de force si quelques pays
seulement comme l'irlande et d'autres
les paradis fiscaux par exemple viennent
expliquer que non ils veulent pas être
partie à l'accord parce que ils veulent
continuer en eau et des paradis fiscaux
très bien sauf que si derrière il ya les
états unis la russie la france allemagne
et peut-être même la chine ses terres
les plus grandes puissances militaires
et économiques
ça risque de mal se passer pour pour ces
petits pays je rappelle quand même que
il ya des mesures qui s'appelle les
embargos de qui peuvent être prises
enfin bon voilà dans le rapport de force
je pense que ces pays n'ont pas les
moyens de grandir d'échapper à des
dispositifs qui sont voulus par les plus
grandes puissances mondiales
et puis j'ajouterai autre chose c'est
que ce serait à l'union européenne alors
de proposer des contreparties à
l'irlande
enfin c'est quand même sur la lys qu on
est un pays comme l'irlande mais les
pays-bas aussi sont concernés dans une
moindre mesure au sein de l'union
européenne qui est pratique une peu été
extrêmement agressive de concurrence
fiscale et sans qu on est on est jamais
rien fait alors qu'on sait que ça porte
préjudice aux états qui pratiquent des
taux d'imposition plus développés donc
oui il faut coopérer internationalement
sans remettre en cause la souveraineté
des états en clair le la conclusion à
laquelle je veux venir c'est que j'ai
expliqué au début qu'on a une lutte
entre le marché et les états nations et
quand je dis le marché en fait c'est les
multinationales les plus riches et donc
c'est tout ce qui va favoriser un
accroissement des inégalités
je crois
les états doivent pouvoir rester maître
en partie de leurs politiques
économiques parce que les cultures sont
différentes et qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
exigences en termes d'égalité et de
redistribution mais en revanche tous les
dispositifs mondiaux qui peuvent
permettre de réguler le marché dans un
sens qui va permettre de réduire les
inégalités parce qu'on va augmenter les
recettes fiscales des états on va
pouvoir financer service public on va
pouvoir redistribuer aux gens qui en ont
besoin
alors tous ces dispositifs la doivent
être poussés au maximum par les plus
grandes puissances économiques et
mondial c'est leur intérêt si elles
veulent préserver la paix sociale le
contrat social et empêcher que des
révoltes populaires des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes
continue et bien à surgir comme ça dans
les années à venir parce que si on
n'atteint pas cet objectif
c'est ce qui va se produire
malheureusement est bon je voudrais pas
dérivé du sujet mais on voit ce que ce à
quoi on assiste en france et notamment
dans l'union européenne c'est qu'à force
de jouer afin d'assister à un creusement
des inégalités
on a un développement des idées
d'extrême droite et des idées
identitaires des idées racistes qui se
développe à vitesse grand v avec des
partis qui est d'extrême droite qui ne
cesse de prendre de l'ampleur
continuons dans cette direction là ne
résolvons pas le problème de la
fiscalité et de la fraude et d'évasion
fiscale et on sait ce que l'histoire
nous en a dit le xxème siècle je crois
nous a quand même donné des cinglante
démonstration que quand on n'agit pas et
quand on aurait pu établir pas un
minimum d'équité dans les sociétés alors
à la fin ça ça se passe toujours très
mal acquis oui mais on est tout à fait
d'accord sur le constat il est
absolument indéniable et une
paupérisation générale des pays
occidentaux
il ya les électeurs de trump ya les gens
qui ont fait le break site en angleterre
et alléger les jaunes en france ces
conditions font qu'il faut absolument
redistribuer plus correctement les
salaires ont effectivement stagné c'est
pas du tout un mythe ya vraiment une
baisse des conditions et il faudrait
distribuer et maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de vivre aujourd'hui est ce
que vraiment l'état et surtout les états
unis où jesse est sont en train de
devenir maîtres comme vous dites de la
situation et ben moi je crains que la
réalité soit que 'corporate' américain
soit aujourd'hui devenu tellement
puissant que n'importe quel président
élu doit négocier avec eux pour des
arrangements qui leur conviennent
on souhaitait parce que si on se revient
sur l'historique de comment l'union
européenne a voulu taxer les gaffes et a
été menacé plusieurs fois de
représailles
et finalement c'est la france tout seul
qui a fait sa taxe gafa et le retard que
ça a pris et la haye les menaces de
représailles contre les secteurs
automobiles allemands irlandais haute
que les états unis ont fait aujourd'hui
on est juste en train d'essayer de
mettre fin à cette guerre économique et
de trouver un arrangement que corporate
america à vous la légitimité du g7 on
peut pas dire qu'elle soit vraiment
solide
parce qu'effectivement et encore la
chine et à la russie a le brésil mais
surtout les petits pays qui doivent
suivre parlons des petits pays machina
pour amener par exemple l'exemple de la
suisse
la suisse s'est totalement soumise à
tous les déserts desiderata de lui un
des états unis et de l'eau cdo ces dix
dernières années
en 2009 elle a abandonné son secret
bancaire pendant que les états unis
maintenaient une opacité financière
extraordinaire dans les états comme le
delaware sur le secteur bancaire avec le
fait la confidentialité sur les comptes
latino-américain panaméen les comptes de
sociétés écrans dans n'importe quelle
banque américaine aujourd'hui son
protégé par une confidentialité donc
l'accord fatca qui oblige tout le monde
à échanger des informations fiscales et
qui a été imposé par les états unis
n'est pas appliquée par les états unis
donc tout ça c'est très réel et on peut
dire que c'est l'irlande est une enclave
fiscale et bat le delaware et le dakota
du nord et le wyoming et tous ses états
américains qui permettent aujourd'hui de
créer des sociétés écrans sont un
problème qui n'a pas été résolue à ce
jour les fortunes physique est ce que
les fortunes physiques ont été concernés
par ce 15% ce 15% et très bien parce
qu'il faut s'attaquer aux
multinationales ça s'est envolé à part
je veux bien mais ben laden avait aussi
promis d'augmenter à 40 % l'impôt sur
ceux qui gagnent plus de 400 millions $
aux états-unis
et ça ça a été abandonnée pour
information donc les fortunes physique
continueront l'échappée alors que c'est
elle qui rassemble en fait les fortunes
les plus vastes dans des structures
comme les trusts les transports
internationaux
mais surtout les petits pays comme la
suisse ou l'irlande ou le luxembourg est
en fait ils n'ont pas
voix au chapitre c'est à dire qu'ils se
voient appliquer des choses qui a été
d'abord décidé au sein du g7
ensuite du gvt a ensuite de l' ocde
ensuite des réunions de banques
centrales ensuite de toutes les grandes
puissances qui vont s'ajouter mais elles
vont finir en bout de chaîne par juste
appliqué des choses mais vont renoncer à
leur souveraineté fiscale
on peut se dire tant mieux parce que
c'est méchant des enclaves fiscale c'est
tout ce qu'elle mérite
mais j'en veux dire la france a maintenu
monaco les états unis ont maintenu le
delaware
il n'y a pas de souci pour tous à hong
kong est une une un centre d'opacité
financière important la chine va aussi
garder personne va lui parler
finalement les puissances nucléaires
celles qui ont vraiment une force de
dissuasion
elles ont toutes des places financières
opaques c'est la realpolitik
il faut voir que ce que vous dites que
ce que vous décrivez comme une
redistribution bienvenus moi je la
souhaite de tout coeur mais je vois
aujourd'hui dans une realpolitik ce qui
se passe vraiment c'est que des
corporations très puissante font les
lois avec des gouvernements puissants
qui arrange plus ou moins sa compassion
et c'est un compromis un compromis qu'on
peut quand même regretter
alors justement est-ce que si on voulait
véritablement que ça change
est ce que le seul moyen ça n'est pas
uniquement la gouvernance mondiale la
seule qui serait capable de de
s'interposer mais pour ça il faudrait
une vraie gouvernance mondiale
c'est-à-dire un état de droit mondial
une police mondiale puisque comme le
disait françois boulot qu'est ce qui va
obliger les pays où les multinationales
à obéir bas par une police je dois pas
et cette police doit être internationale
on l'a vu avec la l'idée de la
superleague idées de tous les clubs les
plus riches en europe on va faire une
super league rien pour nous
baky et ce qui s'y est opposé la
gouvernance mondiale la fifa et elle a
tenu bon et le projet de super league
n'a pas marché parce que la fifa était
forte
si elle avait été faible forcément la
super league aurait marché il nous reste
quatre minutes et demie je les partage
entre michel remy et raphaël prado alors
michel rémy c'est à vous bashkim à ce
que je voulais dire c'est que il faut
attirer une chose on l'a créé
l'organisation mondiale du
commerce mais n'a jamais pu mettre en
place une organisation mondiale de la
finance
c'était une anomalie ça veut dire qu'il
ya une volonté manifeste qu'aucun des
pays n'a intérêt à retrouver à se voir
édicter des règles on va dire bancaire
financière et notamment avec un volet
fiscal donc ce qu'il faut bien voir
c'est que cette fiscalité cet impôt
mondial
il faut aussi se rendre compte que ça
touche la fils la souveraineté d'un pays
et on va sortir d'une crise sanitaire où
l'ensemble des pays vont être
surendettés 1 au sens large du terme
est ce que je veux dire c'est que il
sera difficile de leur faire comprendre
que il faudra entre guillemets les
délégués cette fiscalité à quelqu'un
d'autre donc je pense que il va y avoir
de grands débats et c'est pour cela que
la mise en oeuvre de cette taxe au delà
de l'acceptation il ya la mise en oeuvre
qui importe et qui risque de prendre du
temps
deuxième chose également à supposer
qu'on crée à terme une organisation
mondiale de la finance et que la limite
cette collecte d'impôts mondiale se
fasse au sein de cette organisation
mondiale la question qui va se poser
c'est sur quel critère redistribuées
c'est cet impôt récoltés et donc des
critères objectifs qui permettent à la
limite à chacun de s'y retrouver
et là la difficulté vous pourrez très
bien dire bien comme les pays développés
sont riches
autant les donner aux pays
sous-développés mais il faudra bien ce
moment-là avoir des critères objectifs
et non pas plus ou moins subjectif qui
peuvent être manipulées et c'est à ce
poste ce type de problème parce que si
on veut réduire les inégalités et je
reprendrai un peu ce que dit raphaël
mais en même temps bien sûr sous
développé des moins développés sont en
dehors de la finance
mais si on veut les aider il faudrait
bien trouver des critères objectifs et
là ça pose des problèmes
objectif ça veut dire objectifs et
acceptées par tous et sa satire de
problème là-dessus
enfin le prado
des fois on pose la question faut-il
gouvernance mondiale mais quelque part
elle existe déjà quand on voit l'om
s'est par exemple il est un organe de
règlement des différends qui permet de
sanctionner les pays qui respectent pas
les règles du commerce et aura
effectivement comme ça vient d'être dit
on peut être que frappé de voir
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas ce genre de
mécanisme est clairement ça serait
souhaitable et je suis très surpris
d'ailleurs d'entendre votre
intervenantes qui au nom du
souverainiste dans discours anti
américains nous défend le s'ouvrait la
souveraineté des paradis fiscaux
européens de continuer avec des paradis
fiscaux je veux dire ça me semble
complètement surréaliste au nom d'un
discours contre la gouvernance mondiale
de dire ben allal et luxembourg a
largement le droit de continuer à faire
de la concurrence fiscale et à la volée
les autres fils et qui font d'eux
fiscalité nous ce qu'on défend on n'est
pas les seuls à défendre c'est la
question d'une coque fiscal c'est à dire
même si on ne fantasme pas sur ce que ce
qu'est la coop en matière
d'environnement au moins on a vu quand
même que ça permettait de prendre en
compte par exemple la vie des pays les
plus prêts que les plus pauvres et ceux
qui sont les plus confrontés au
changement climatique
on pourrait s'imaginer que là c'est pas
dans un cadre du g20 au dos et des oeufs
et encore moins de ce g7 qu'ils
considèrent comme illégitime de régler
cette question là ça serait beaucoup
plus logique de le régler dans un cadre
onusien a rénové certainement mais en
tout cas qui permettrait de donner une
voix à tous les pays et pas simplement
au pays les plus puissants
leur dernier mot myret zaki très vite
oui je dois répondre l'histoire de
l'anti américanisme souverainiste là où
c'est complètement n'importe quoi pas du
tout j'explique jusque le souverainisme
fiscal est à géométrie variable
les grands pays où un certain subban et
fiscales ils peuvent faire l'agenda
tandis que les petits pays ne peuvent
pas le faire mais des paradis fiscaux il
y en a de toutes les tailles et surtout
les plus grands est-ce que j'ai été plus
clair à françois boulot il reste 45
secondes c'est parfait ça me laisse tout
le temps qu'il me faut le précédent
intervenants
économiste disait qu'il n'y a jamais eu
de système de régulation de la finance
aurait été si ça s'appelait britton
woods des accords de bretton-woods au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale y
avait une instance supranationale qui
s'appelait le fonds monétaire
international
et comme par hasard il n'y avait pas
d'endettement public avant que les états
unis mettre fin à ces accords et je
pense que l'accord sur la fiscalité la
sera un échec parce qu'il est totalement
insuffisant et il sera inadapté on leur
en expliquer pourquoi mais de la même
manière il faudrait une coopération
interne l international pour taxer la
spéculation financière et pour réguler à
nouveau les mener au niveau mondial mais
je crois malheureusement que les esprits
ne sont pas prêts il faudra des
événements bien plus dramatique pour
décider les hommes et les états à
coopérer davantage pour construire un
monde plus juste
michel rémy très rapidement puisque vous
voulez répondre et réprimé au jeu répond
à françois à françois simplement bien
sûr que le fmi a existé mais son rôle
entre lignes de son rôle initial est
actuellement et est un peu perverti
d'une certaine manière ce que j'appelle
quand je dis organisation mondiale de la
finance c'est qu'elle justement et règle
les différends un peu dans une certaine
manière ce qu'a dit raphaël en disant on
se situe des règles et s'il ya des
différents on les règle
or le fmi n'a pas de l'organe de
règlement des différends et aujourd'hui
il leur en fait il devient plutôt un
pompier qu'un on va dire d'un jantes 15
gendarmes du système monétaire
international
voilà merci les accords de bretton-woods
je vous remercie tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]